one governor by the way who has become a
beacon of hope for americans in florida
and beyond
governor ron desantis he's standing up
against critical race theory
against rioting lawlessness and against
lockdowns he's joining us tonight with
reaction
governor good to see you thank you for
being with us let me read what you said
about
critical race theory you said the woke
class wants to teach kids to hate each
other
rather than teaching them how to read
we're not going to let them bring
nonsense ideology into florida schools
you love the state you love the country
and it's unthinkable there are people in
positions of leadership in the federal
government
who believe that we should teach kids to
hate
our country we're not going to stand for
it in florida tell us why
well first of all sean we're happy to
have abandoned in florida
it's not going to be allowed in florida
classrooms spending
tax dollars to teach kids that america
is a rotten place
is absolutely unacceptable if you look
at how
some of this stuff manifests itself in
classrooms
that we have seen examples of it's not a
conspiracy theory
dividing kids based on race trying to
say some are oppressors and some are
oppressed based on race
attacking law enforcement and saying law
enforcement
attacks people based on race those
things are poison
that is not what we should be doing what
we should be doing is solid curriculum
based on the actual facts of american
history and teaching kids what it means
to be an american
and part of what it means to be an
american as we judge people
not on the color of their skin but on
the content of their character
you know i look at florida where i'm
leaning heavily to moving
very soon and i look at your state
against critical race theory you have no
state income tax you have no inheritance
tax
uh you are for law and order and you
reward good policing to keep people safe
and secure
you go down the list you didn't have
draconian shutdowns
this is there's such a dramatic
difference now emerging between
red states like yours and blue states
like new york
california new jersey and illinois
i don't how do you reconcile these
differences they're so dramatic
well i think part of it is we have a
conservative approach
they have a left-wing approach but i
think some of this sean is just common
sense i mean for example
we have the lowest per capita tax burden
in the country
but the reason that we are doing well is
because
people respond to that they want to live
in a place
that's well governed with low taxes so
we actually now are collecting more
revenue
than we can forecast or even keep up
with with those lower rates
and it's all about understanding that
you're trying to expand your economic
base
obviously things like law and order
those are just common sense
things that you have to do if you don't
have public safety you don't really have
anything
and then of course making sure we have
good curriculum in schools
protecting things like women's athletics
which we were able to do i signed a bill
a couple weeks
ago we really believe that on the key
issues that matter for floridians
we're leading and we're getting things
done you know when you look at the
differences especially like with
california
today is the first official day that
they're reopening the state but they're
not really fully reopening the state
then they've adopted these covet
passports i noticed there's a little bit
of a controversy emerging with the
cruise line
industry which is big in florida and to
your credit by the way
you've been fighting for them to get
back online as quickly as possible
a lot of jobs are at stake a lot of
money for florida's economy at stake
uh yet some of the cruise lines want
these passports
or vaccination proof and you've held the
line you said no passports
yeah i know exactly just understand john
cdc has shut the cruise lines down for
over a year
we sued cdc to be able to get them off
of this so that the cruise lines could
function in florida
of course they're going to have to do it
consistent with florida law
we are not allowing discrimination based
on vaccination status what the cdc wants
to do
is effectively ban young kids from
cruisers because
they're not even eligible to get
vaccinated and yet they would count that
against the cruise ship so our view is
you know non-discrimination
understanding kids should be able to go
on and also understanding people have
recovered from covid
and also are immune and they may not
have taken the vaccine at that point
so we think that that's better than
forcing people to divulge private health
information
and discriminate against people who may
have had reason not to get the vaccine
governor i would say this to people in
new york new jersey michigan
california that are moving to florida i
know you you welcome them with open arms
i would just like to request on your
behalf that they leave
their radical leftist liberal socialist
policies in the state they come from
and don't bring that voting record with
you and ruin the new state that you're
going to
i think that's a fair request i hope you
agree with that well the good thing is
a lot of them are leaving because of
those radical policies
and they've actually been repelled and
they're coming because we are an oasis
of freedom so i think that that's really
a good sign
and by the way you spend half as much as
new york with no income tax and better
infrastructure
i think that speaks volumes governor
good to see you thank you hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else